so over the past few months i've been  getting a lot of comments on my videos  and people  asking me am i related to nicholas cage  i look a lot like nicholas cage and to  me this is just  totally ridiculous because everybody  looks like nicholas cage  and i have the proof to back it up  pregnant women look like nicolas cage  your rib cage looks like nicolas cage  e.t looks like nicolas cage  gandalf yoda hillary clinton  little mermaid mona lisa bill clinton  albert einstein the statue of liberty  biggie buzz lightyear  princess leia the green lantern  miley cyrus barack obama everybody looks  like nicholas cage  i don't know why you guys would say that  but i'm deeply hurt  i'm taking names and i'm gonna remember  who you are